[Applause]
and finally new rule now that we live in
an age of uber corporate responsibility
where every large company in america
bends over backwards to get on the
politically correct side of every issue
hollywood has to tell us why doesn't
that include gun violence
[Laughter]
when liberals scream do something after
a mass shooting why aren't we also
dealing with the fact that the average
american kid sees 200 000 acts of
violence on screens before the age of 18
and that according to the fbi one of the
warning signs of a potential school
shooter is a fascination with
violence-filled entertainment
it's funny hollywood is the wokest place
on earth in every other area of social
responsibility they have intimacy
coordinators on set to chaperone sex
scenes they hire sensitivity readers to
go through and edit scripts disney stood
up to the don't say gay law another
studio spent 10 million dollars to
digitally remove kevin spacey from a
movie
but when it comes to the unbridled
romanticization of gun violence
crickets
weird the only thing we don't call a
trigger is the one that actually has a
trigger
[Applause]
if you make a movie today you can't show
bullying fat shaming [ __ ] shaming girl
chasing gay baiting ethnic stereotypes
or underage hookups where drinking is
involved you know what we used to call
comedies
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but
but those things are bad and everyone
knows you can't platform bad things you
know what you can still platform one guy
who's the hero
getting over a grudge by mowing down a
multitude of human beings
because no impressionable young male
would ever imitate that
now the usual suspects on the far left
will say that i'm delivering some sort
of conservative rant here or that i'm
undermining gun control no it's neither
it's just what's real
there's a pie chart of why mass
shootings happen and we don't know
exactly how much of each of the pieces
is responsible but the major ones are
mental health
that is broken young men who feel like
losers and want the world to hurt like
they do
easy access to guns
kids having smart phones which makes
losers feel even worse because of the
bullying and all the fake lives that
look better than theirs and yes yes
crazy amounts of gun violence and movies
and tv
we don't show movie characters smoking
anymore because it might look cool and
influence children but
you're telling me these cool dudes don't
influence them
[Music]
[Applause]
they say the success of top gun maverick
will be a great boost to navy pilot
recruitment
great but then you can't say it's just a
movie when it's this
that was cool
and it's not just and it's not just the
idea presented over and over and over
again that guns are the best solution to
life's problems it's why the hero is
using a gun they call them action movies
they should call them revenge movies
because that's the plot of every one of
them and there's a sick similarity in
the revenge fantasies hollywood turns
out and those of school shooters
i want revenge
i want them to know
that death is coming
yeah there's nothing
they can do to stop it
here's a list of just the action movies
that have vengeance in the title
blind vengeance bitter vengeance crime
engines sweet vengeance dark vengeance
fast vengeance blue vengeance forced
vengeance heated vengeance naked
vengeance acts of vengeance deadly
vengeance out preventions bound of
vengeance fistful of engines streets of
vengeance angel of vengeance ministry of
vengeance with a vengeance codename
vengeance fort vengeance kickboxer
vengeance ninja vengeance
and
taste of vengeance my least favorite
chinese restaurant
[Applause]
vengeance has been in more movies than
pets and sunglasses
there's even a movie called i am
vengeance retaliation even though
retaliation means vengeance
it's like calling your movie i am
pregnant expecting
getting revenge on them that wronged you
is what happens it's all that happens in
movies that are made for and loved by
young men it's the male version of
getting your groove back or meryl streep
getting a big kitchen
like
like every school shooter our movie
heroes are grievance collectors and when
it comes to action movies there's one
story he was a nice guy but they pushed
him too far and now it's on
they took my daughter they killed my
father they killed my fiance they killed
my family they killed my family again
they killed my puppy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all of which doesn't just create a
culture of violence but a culture of
justified violence
liberals hated it when
kyle rittenhouse they hated him but
somehow the liberal capital of the world
is okay with making 500 movies about
vigilantes
they hate it when gun people say it
takes a good guy with a gun to stop a
bad guy with a gun
but then they endlessly produce movies
with that exact plot
now thanks one guy
now am i saying don't make these movies
no not at all i've never for censorship
or organizing society around what crazy
people might do but don't look me in the
eye and tell me this isn't a big part of
the problem every bad idea a kid can get
about how to handle feeling abused and
disrespected is in all these movies
including the ridiculous cliche that if
you are the good guy the avenging angel
who's doing all the killing
you never get shot
and if you do it's nothing
this is how bad guys get shot in movies
don't applaud that really
this is how heroes get shot
it's nothing
you just put a little gauze on it it's
nothing
it's like a birthday punch
that's the message from the people who
hate guns the loudest don't worry about
them if you get shot the worst that'll
happen is you might have to sit beside
the ambulance with a blanket
you